[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
war herzlich willkommen im sport gibt es
heute fußball
jetzt aber erst mal einen blick auf die
großen themen allen voran der ukraine
russland konflikt
nervenkrieg um die ukraine moskau erwägt
die separatisten gebiete im osten
anzuerkennen die kriegsgefahr bleibt
hoch
hoffnung für die deutsche impfquote der
impfstoff nova wachs wird bald
ausgeliefert und soll auch im skeptiker
überzeugen
und feuer inferno in essen ein
wohnkomplex brennt nieder die helfer
müssen aber nur einige leichtverletzte
versorgen
noch heute will der russische präsident
putin entscheiden ob er lohans und
donezk in der ost ukraine als unabhängig
anerkannt das wäre eine eskalation in
der ohnehin angespannten lage die
ukraine fordert unterdessen eine
dringlichkeitssitzung des un
sicherheitsrates und aus dem
ostukrainischen gebieten werden
weiterhin kämpfe gemeldet axel sturm
berichtet
bilder die aus den jetzt stammen sollen
gefechte in der nacht zwischen
separatistischen und ukrainischen
kämpfern angeblich nicht zu verifizieren
verbreitet über telegramm die lage
bleibt angespannt und sie hat sich noch
verkompliziert
lieber wladimir wladimirowitsch im namen
der volksrepublik denn jetzt bitte ich
sie die donezker volksrepublik als
unabhängigen demokratischen legalen
sozialen staat anzuerkennen
bonn jetzt soll staat werden ebenso wie
lohans der stachel im fleisch der
ukraine die beiden bezirke besetzt vom
prorussischen separatisten seit 2014
fragen jetzt in moskau an ob man nicht
als staat anerkannt werden könne am
nachmittag überträgt das russische
fernsehen diese bilder eine sitzung des
sicherheitsrates in moskau
der hauptgrund für dieses treffen wir
müssen uns austauschen und weitere
schritte besprechen wir müssen über den
wunsch der selbsternannten volksrepublik
lohans und tom jetzt gesprächen deren
anführer und bitten ihre unabhängigkeit
anzuerkennen
deutlich sichtbar dieses treffen wurde
für die kameras inszeniert auch der vom
präsidenten geforderte austausch unter
den mächtigen im kabinett alles soll
eine nachricht transportieren russland
müsse zu seinen anhängern stehen
die ukraine braucht diese territorien
nicht die einwohner dieser territorien
haben seit jahren von der ukraine keine
unterstützung erhalten im gegenteil sie
waren massen repressionen ausgesetzt
putin inszeniert sich als schutzmacht
der separatisten noch hat er keine order
gegeben aber er weiß wenn russland dann
jetzt und hans als staaten bezeichnet
ist das abkommen von minsk geschichte
das einzige das zurzeit grundlage sein
könnte für eine deeskalation
er wolle genau darauf schauen mit
unseren korrespondenten in russland
christiansen und den usa thema tee
wissen guten abend an sie beide kommen
wir als erstes zu ihnen nach moskau
christian eine anerkennung der
separatisten gebiete was bedeutet das
genau
ja die mitglieder des nationalen
sicherheitsrates die haben sich alle
dafür ausgesprochen diese gebiete
anzuerkennen aber in russland ist es so
dass zum schluss nur eine entscheidet
und das ist wladimir putin und diese
entscheidung hat er noch nicht getroffen
aber sollte russland diese gebiete
anerkennen ja dann wären diese minsker
friedensvereinbarung von 2015 die wären
tot die wurden zwar nie umgesetzt aber
darin steht dass die separatisten
gebiete weiter zur ukraine gehören und
einen autonomiestatus bekommen und jetzt
dann wenn es eine anerkennung geben
würde dann könnte russland dort auch
truppen stationieren soldaten
stationieren wie das schon in anderen
abtrünnigen provinzen passiert ist wir
warten hier minütlich auf die
entscheidung war die metin will sie
jetzt bald im staatsfernsehen verkündet
der kamera wird also eine anerkennung
relatives in washington wie reagieren
die usa darauf
ja die usa sehen das als eine seite aus
genau dem drehbuch dass sie vladimir
putin ja vorwerfen nachdem er in den
letzten wochen vorgegangen ist wenn es
eine anerkennung gäbe dann wäre das aus
sicht des weißen hauses ein schwerer
bruch des völkerrechts einbruch ein
einseitiger bruch des minsker abkommens
und das müsste dann konsequenzen nach
sich ziehen möglicherweise sanktionen
weil in der vergangenen woche die
verbündeten schon so etwas bei einer
anerkennung anerkennung angekündigt
hatten jetzt hängt dann von putin ab ob
er dann auch soldaten in diese
völkerrechtswidrig anerkannten gebiete
schicken würde tut er das dann würde das
weiße haus sicherlich die
gesprächsangebote der außenminister aber
auch eines gesprächs zwischen beiden und
putin vom tisch nehmen solange man es
noch auf dem tisch halten weil man am
ende vielleicht sagen will man hat alles
versucht um eine invasion zu verhindern
auch je länger es dauert desto
schwieriger wird es für die russischen
truppen in den witterungsbedingungen in
der gegend also das weiße haus lässt den
diplomatischen kanal offen aber ist sehr
sehr skeptisch wenn es seine anerkennung
gibt dann geht man von einer invasion
aus dankeschön elmar theveßen in usa und
christian senn in russland die
diplomatischen kanäle sollen offen
bleiben ja diesen angespannten stunden
gibt es da weiterhin versuchen eine
lösung zu finden
wohin hat dass ein telefonat zwischen
bundeskanzler scholz und putin gegeben
theo koll in berlin was ist bei diesem
gespräch heraus gekommen also jedenfalls
keine guten nachrichten denn nach dem
was aus dem kanzleramt zu erfahren ist
hat olaf scholz russische pläne scharf
verurteilt die beiden sogenannten
volksrepublik in der ost ukraine als
unabhängige staaten anzuerkennen dass
stünden im krassen widerspruch zu den
minister abkommen zur friedlichen
beilegung und wäre ein einseitiger bruch
der vereinbarung wenn man diese warnung
des kanzleramtes und die ankündigung
dass putin sich noch heute abend im
fernsehen äussern wird zusammen nimmt
dann liegt der schluss nahe dass es
heute zu dieser hochproblematischen
anerkennung der pro-russischen gebiete
kommen wird und das wäre eine massive
verschärfung der situation olaf scholz
berät sich offensichtlich zur stunde
unter anderem mit dem präsidenten
frankreichs und der ukraine der erhoffte
gipfel beiden putin hat im kanzler
telefonat mit putin offensichtlich keine
große rolle gespielt auch das ist kein
gutes zeichen
die seien schätzungen theo koll
sollte russland die ukraine angreifen
wollen europa und die usa sanktionen
verhängen allerdings ist die europäische
union da uneins baltische staaten wie
litauen wollen sofortige strafmaßnahmen
unter anderem deutschland und österreich
sehen die zeit für sanktionen dagegen
noch nicht gekommen das ganze hat heute
die eu-außenministerin und minister bei
ihrem treffen in brüssel beschäftigt mit
dabei ihr ukrainischer kollege florian
neumann berichtet wenn die metropole war
dieser tage nach brüssel reist dann
nicht um sich freundliche worte
abzuholen der ukrainische außenminister
fordert am morgen taten von der eu
es gibt gute und legitime gründe einige
sanktionen gegen russland schon jetzt zu
verhängen huber verweist auf den
russischen truppenaufmarsch der sein
land massiv unter druck setzt doch noch
wie die mehrheit in brüssel lieber
abwarten
sanktionen sind eine reaktion ist diese
pläne hat bestrafen war so will das kann
man nicht im vorfeld machen und sollte
man noch nicht wie du nord wir müssen
nicht bis zu einem militärischen angriff
fahren ich kann sagen die ukraine wird
ja bereits angegriffen
die deutsche außenministerin hält sich
öffentlich dazu bedeckt annalena
baerbock wendet sich stattdessen direkt
an den russischen präsidenten ihr warten
auf sie damit wir gemeinsam für frieden
und sicherheit in der ukraine sorgen und
falls das nicht gelingt will man
gegenmaßnahmen offenbar vor allem im
finanzsektor verhängen
finanzsanktionen bedeuten für den kreml
dass wenn sie militärische aggression
gegen die ukraine fahren
russland im prinzip abgeschnitten wird
von den internationalen finanzmärkten es
wäre europas schärfste schwert gerade
deshalb zögern sie noch europa hatte in
den letzten wochen ausreichend zeit sich
auf mögliche sanktionen vorzubereiten
jetzt liegen alle texte fertig auf dem
tisch doch weil die besonders wirksamen
sanktionen etwa im finanzsektor auch die
eu selbst treffen würden will man sie
erst verhängen wenn es wirklich nötig
ist
neue meldungen zur ukraine krise kommen
quasi im minutentakt sie können alle
aktuellen entwicklung in russland
ukraine konflikt jederzeit in unserer
zdf heute app verfolgen kompakt im
live-blog
blicken wir jetzt auf corona da ist die
zahl der neuinfektionen erneut
rückläufig dem lkw wurden binnen 24
stunden 73 1867 positive tests gemeldet
der sieben tage instituts steigt
allerdings nur leicht auf 1300 46,8 und
viele fälle sind offenbar nicht erfasst
weil wohl etliche menschen ihre
infektion nicht mit einem pcr test
bestätigt lassen haben
grund genug über das impfen zu sprechen
schauen wir wie es da läuft in
deutschland sind 76,2 prozent der
bevölkerung einmal geimpft fast genauso
viele
75,2 prozent haben zwei dosen bekommen
und 56,3 eine auffrischimpfung nicht
geimpft sind
23,8 prozent jetzt könnte das impfen
wieder fahrt aufnehmen denn in dieser
woche wird erstmals das neue präparat
nowaks geliefert und das soll auch die
überzeugen die demenz cap tisch
gegenüber stehen so ein glas berichtet
das ist er der neue impfstoff gegen
krohne in dieser woche sollen die ersten
1,4 millionen nowaks dosen beim bund
ankommen dann an die länder verteilt
werden bundesweit gibt es mehrere
zehntausend voranmeldungen für einen no
wax impfung hier in stuttgart sind es
rund 800 teilweise werden unaufgefordert
begründung geschickt als ganz emotionale
ausführliche erklärungen wo wir sehen
da hat man sich gequält gehadert
durchaus den wunsch aber nach einer
impfung aber eine skepsis gegenüber den
amerikanern stoffen der nova wachs
impfstoff unterscheidet sich von den
bisher zugelassenen corona impfstoffen
nutzt eine seit jahrzehnten eingesetzte
technologie er enthält einen im labor
künstlich hergestellten ungefährlichen
teil des corona erregers das sogenannte
spike protein auf das reagiert das
immunsystem dann zum beispiel
grippeimpfstoffe funktionieren genauso
zunächst einmal soll der neue impfstoff
vorrangig für bisher ungeimpfte
beschäftigte im gesundheitswesen
eingesetzt werden dann für alle anderen
interessenten wir freuen uns wenn sich
hier noch einige menschen impfen lassen
werden es gibt einen harten kern glaube
ich die sich mit keinem impfstoff impfen
lassen wollen und an die kommt man
schlicht drin zum beispiel die die in
sozialen netzwerken mit drastischen
worten vor nowaks warnen ein grund ein
sogenannter wirkverstärker im impfstoff
in dem experten allerdings keine gefahr
sehen dieser ganz spezielle impfstoff
ist von der firma selber nochmal
entwickelt aber diese stoffklasse kennt
man und habe ich auch keine bedenken und
so dürfte der nova wachs impfstoff
zumindest einige bisher ungeimpfte
überzeugen im
bundesgesundheitsministerium rechnet man
mit ersten impfungen ab der nächsten
oder übernächsten woche
während in deutschland noch über eine
impfpflicht diskutiert wird sollen in
england auch die letzten corona
maßnahmen fallen premierminister johnson
stellte im parlament sein plan für ein
leben mit
corona soll anderen
infektionskrankheiten gleichgestellt
werden infizierte müssen sich nicht mehr
selbst isolieren auch die kostenlosen
tests sollen wegfallen
expertinnen und experten bezeichnen die
geplanten schritte als zuvor ein
es war in deutschland der dritte schwere
sturm innerhalb nur weniger tage tief
antonia kam mit orkanartigen böen und
bescherte vielen eine unruhige nacht
etliche bäume stürzten auf straßen
oberleitungen und autos in
norddeutschland bei pinneberg standen
wieder ganze landstriche unter wasser
zahlreiche züge fielen aus wie hier auf
der strecke hamburg-hannover weiter im
süden sogar schnee in baden württemberg
bei ravensburg rutschte ein bus mit 30
schulkindern in den graben niemand wurde
verletzt
der sturm der vergangenen nacht hat auch
noch eine andere zerstörerische wirkung
die kräftigen windböen fachten ein feuer
an dass an einem wohnkomplex in essen
ausgebrochen war schnell fraßen sich die
flammen über die fassade ins gebäude 35
wohnungen brannten vollständig aus drei
menschen wurden verletzt die feuerwehr
in essen spricht von einem noch nie
dagewesenen brand ralph goldmann
es ist nach mitternacht als die essener
feuerwehr zunächst zu einem balkon brand
gerufen wird als sie ankommt steht fast
ein ganzer häuserblock mit mehr als 100
wohnungen in flammen 35 brennen komplett
aus nur wenige bewohner erleiden
rauchgasvergiftungen mehr als 100 können
in sicherheit gebracht werden sie kommen
vorerst in einem nahegelegenen hörsaal
der universität unter ich habe nur
ausweis und papier gepackt und mich
eingezogen mein kind geweckt
und ich konnte schwer denkt man im
augenblick muss ich gestehen mann ist
unterstützer englisch und mit all dem
haben gut all dem was einem lieb
geworden ist die ganzen erinnerungen
sind ja alles offen das gebäude wurde
erst 2015 errichtet der brandschutz laut
eigentümer erst im vergangenen jahr
überprüft das feuer aber fraß sich
offenbar nicht durch das gebäude
hindurch sondern sprang auch wegen der
starken winde außen von einer wohnung zu
anderen
die ersten kräfte an festgestellt dass
das feuer sich entlang der balkone
fassade über das gesamte über die
gesamte gebäudefront ausgebreitet hat da
sind dann scheiben geplatzt von diesen
scheiben aus in die wohnung unklar ist
noch warum die fassade trotz eigentlich
moderner dämmung so schnell komplett in
flammen stand die einsatzkräfte konnten
noch nicht in die ausgebrannten
wohnungen denn das haus ist
einsturzgefährdet sicher scheint aber es
gibt keine weiteren vermissten sobald
das gebäude wieder betreten werden darf
will die kriminalpolizei mit den
ermittlungen zur brandursache beginnen
inflation war vier jahre lang kein thema
mehr jetzt umso mehr heizen wohn
autofahren alles kostet mehr und auch im
supermarkt macht sich die inflation
bemerkbar
einige beispiele gemüse 8 prozent teurer
als vor einem jahr butter ein dickes
plus von 19 prozent oder etwa speiseöl
sogar plus 23 prozent das summiert sich
an der kasse und heftig angezogen hat
auch der kaffeepreis wie es da aussieht
zeigt petra meyer
bohnenkaffee duftend und frisch geröstet
das lieblingsgetränk der deutschen mit
168 litern jährlichen pro kopf konsum
seit heute wird es teurer große anbieter
tchibo von zwischen 50 cent und 1 euro
30 mehr ein grund dafür die
einkaufspreise für rohkaffee haben sich
auf dem weltmarkt innerhalb eines jahres
fast verdoppelt von 1 eur 38 auf 2 eur
53 für ein knappes pfund weiterer
preistreiber sind ernteausfälle im
letzten jahr konnte man beobachten dass
es in brasilien immer häufiger zu
extremwetter ereignissen gekommen ist
und diese extremwetter ereignisse haben
die ernte von der arabica bohne
maßgeblich beeinträchtigt
klimaschwankungen dürre und kälte setzen
den empfindlichen kaffeepflanzen zu für
kleinbauern die oft nur zehn prozent des
preises erhalten bedeutet eine missernte
oft den ruinen das rohkaffee angebot
wird knapper das hebt die preise und
dann sind da noch die transportprobleme
durch corona also es ist immer noch so
dass die die häfen durcheinandergebracht
wurden also dass die container nicht da
sind wo sie sein sollen und dass ja die
kapazitäten einfach nicht da sind um die
ware auch zu verladen kleine röstereien
wie kaffee in hamburg versuchen ihre
café bauer zu unterstützen durch
vorfinanzierung ihrer ernten und eine
faire gewinnbeteiligung sie zahlen ihnen
30 prozent ihres verkaufspreises
soll die winterspiele sind ja vorbei
jetzt denn die fußballspieler angesagt
haben ja und was für welche gestern
abend die drei sonntags kicks in der
bundesliga mit insgesamt 18 toren
schauen wir als erstes auf den klassiker
bewusst ja gegen borussia 6 zu 0 hieß es
am ende für dortmund 1 auswärts debakel
für gladbach
das war weit mehr als nur eine bloße
niederlage für borussia mönchengladbach
dabei hatten auch die gäste zahlreiche
hochkarätige chancen durch entweder hieß
bvb-keeper kuba glänzend oder aber es
fehlten die notwendigen zentimeter für
das glücklose team von trainer adi
hütter auf der anderen seite hatte
dortmund einen überragenden marco reus
der zwei tore selbst erzielte und der
drei assists wie hierfür mukoko
servierte sechs tore auch ohne den
verletzten topstürmer holland diesen
beim unberechenbaren bvb wieder ein
vorsichtiges lächeln zu während einem
die gladbacher auch auf der tribüne nur
noch leid tun konnten
ja starker heimsieg für dortmund
schlimme heimpleite dagegen für die
hertha 1 zu 6 stand es am ende für die
dezimierte berliner mannschaft im spiel
gegen leipzig er will jetzt auf einem
champions league platz härter rutscht
auf rang 15 noch erreicht der berliner
trainer sein team glaubt jedenfalls der
manager den bobic sieht gestern zwei
spiele der korona bedingt ohne sechs
spielen härter ein gutes und ein
miserables die zäsur dieses foul zuerst
das gute berliner spiel schnell erzählt
rückstand in der zwanzigsten ausgleich
kurz nach der pause durch petric aber
nach einer stunde die bereits gesehene
strafraum aktion gegen kongo
platzverweis kempf und rückstand hertha
jetzt geht es dahin mit den berlinern
vier weitere leipziger tore 1 kug uhr
trifft doppelt paulsen zuletzt 16
trainer korb gut trotz abstiegsgefahr
kämpferisch
hat uns weh getan wird uns aber nicht
um die punkte nach leipzig die
sportkleidung für die treusten die
berliner gestern vor allem gut im geben
ja alle begegnung mit allen toren des 23
spieltages bei uns zu sehen beim zdf
heute.de und in der heute
noch das wetter wechselhaft regnerisch
und windig bleibt es auch morgen der
mittwoch bringt mir sonne ganz genau
erfahren sie das gleich von katja
horneffer christian sievers hat dann um
21 45 das heute-journal für sie auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend die kaltfront von sturmtief
antonia hat uns schon heute vormittag
ostwärts verlassen sie sehen hier einen
kleinen wolken wirbel und der brachte
heute noch mal kräftige schauer mit zum
teil auch gewitter das waren schnee
regen und graupelschauer auch kräftige
böen sind noch unterwegs das gilt auch
jetzt noch am abend und in der nacht
diese schnee regen und graupelschauer
inklusive gewitter ziehen weiter
südostwärts an der nordseeküste ist das
dagegen zum teil klar bei nordwest wird
die schneefallgrenze liegt etwa bei 500
meter machen sie sich also auf
gefährlich glatte straßen gefasst denn
fast überall sinken die temperaturen in
den kritischen bereich zwischen plus 3
und minus ein grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen dann
zwischen 4 grad zum beispiel im
thüringer wald und zehn oder elf grad am
rhein und auch morgen vormittag gibt es
noch weitere schneeregenschauer die
ziehen hier langsam richtung südosten ab
dann gibt es einen freundlichen streifen
von der ostseeküste bis zum oberrhein
bevor dann von westen neuer regen
herankommt und oberhalb von etwa 600
meter ist doch wieder schnee dabei am
mittwoch wird es dann von besten
deutlich sonniger donnerstag und freitag
sind dann schon wieder etwas
wechselhafter und der freitag auch
kälter guten abend